hola y bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 nuestra mitad de hoy es a ti
te sentís la prometida del periodista
saudí asesinado llama al show y se
acompaña desde estambul muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros hoy
gracias yamaha jog y era un conocido
columnista del washington por el
presidente en eeuu y un destacado
crítico del príncipe heredero mohamed
bin salman fascinado dentro del
consulado saudí en estambul en octubre
de 2018
hace unos días el gobierno
estadounidense publicó un muy esperado
informe de su principal agencia de
inteligencia que determinó que el
príncipe heredero había aprobado el
asesinato de llamar a xavi este informe
fue desclasificado por el presidente
bailén cuya administración decidió
sancionar a 76 saudíes pero no al
príncipe lideró cuál es su reacción
mi primera reacción fue
creí cuando vi la noticia o leí por
primera vez la noticia en las redes
sociales creo que es un comienzo
significativo lo que hicieron como
administraciones la administración
bailén pero creo que no es suficiente si
no hay ninguna acción o ninguna sanción
contra el asesino
entonces lo que está diciendo es que
está bien sancionar a 76 a 10 el
departamento del tesoro también sancionó
a la unidad que supuestamente asesinó a
jamal pero usted quiere sanciones contra
el príncipe heredero no es así
en cierto modo es cierto pero no estoy
hablando de las 76 personas estoy
hablando de quién es el asesino
quién es el máximo responsable de este
asesinato
su cómplice sin ninguna sanción o sin
ninguna acción contra él
qué significa si se castiga a las otras
personas no es nada no es justicia no es
una justicia correcta
le decepciona que el gobierno de bailén
diga ok volaremos con el príncipe
heredero solo con el rey parece que
tienen miedo de sancionar el príncipe
heredero por lo que la inteligencia de
eeuu dice que hizo que aprobó el
asesinato de jamal a xavi
creo que es hora de hacer lo correcto
ese es mi mensaje para bailén
no sé lo que baile empieza sobre el
príncipe heredero pero debería hacer más
y debería hacer lo correcto
y durante su campaña electoral dijo que
lo castigaría ahora es el momento de
hacer lo correcto no sólo hablar o
mostrar un informe sin tomar ninguna
medida contra el verdadero asesino o sin
dar una verdadera orden porque nos
muestra el informe
hay dos proyectos de ley que fueron
presentados en el congreso de eeuu
pidiendo sanciones contra mohamed bin
salman obviamente esto es solo el
comienzo para presentar el proyecto de
ley pero espera que es el presidente de
eeuu no actúa el congreso de estaciones
para decidir en la forma que usted lo
está pidiendo the way the calling ford
como usted dijo hay una gran pelea en
este momento en eeuu y veremos lo que
pasará pero espero que el proyecto de
ley del congreso haga lo correcto
también hay algo que ocurrió hace unos
días la organización reporteros sin
fronteras entabló una demanda contra
mohamed bin salman ante la fiscalía
federal de alemania acusa el príncipe
heredero de asesinar a llamar a yogui y
también de detener a otros 34
periodistas dicen que son crímenes
contra la humanidad cuál es su reacción
ante esta demanda presentada en alemán
si los apoyen también los voy a apoyar y
es por los periodistas que están en la
cárcel ahora mismo en arabia saudita
para protegerlos para darles una luz y
apoyo a esta organización y su informe
sports
la pregunta es entiendo que usted está
pidiendo justicia pero si tuviera que
elegir qué haría usted también presentó
una demanda en eeuu hay una demanda en
alemania en este momento qué es lo que
espera exactamente para que se haga
justicia con llamar ayoví
ok este pequeño al principio buscábamos
la verdad
y ahora conseguimos la verdad y la
verdad es clara es hora de actuar es
hora de tomar medidas contra el asesino
tiene que rendir cuentas
ahora mismo estoy pidiendo que se rindan
cuentas y ya veremos
no hay una palabra para lo que le está
preguntando vivo si no sé el tipo de
justicia en este caso porque es muy
complicado
pero debemos pedir más debemos hacer más
debemos buscar más para conseguir
justicia por llamar
y espera que los países cambien sus
relaciones diplomáticas con la arabia
saudita que eeuu europa cambiar su forma
de relacionarse
eso espero y luego ya veremos juntas no
sé nada más pero tiene que cambiar tiene
que hacerlo
tiene que cambiar quiero preguntarle
sobre usted es decir obviamente este ha
sido un periodo muy difícil que está
haciendo ahora obviamente está buscando
justicia atrás ya mal pero como está
siguiendo con su vida en este momento
estoy bien me estoy recuperando puedo
decir lo alcance ha pasado dos años y ha
sido muy duro para mí para ser sincera
que mi vida ha cambiado el trato de
volver a empezar puedo decirlo así
volver a empezar
[Música]
y está en contacto con otras personas
que luchan por los derechos humanos en
arabia saudita
específicamente las mujeres han estado
luchando creo que ahora es el momento de
insistir en esta cuestión de promover
los derechos humanos
no tengo ninguna conexión con ellos ni
con ningún defensor de los derechos
humanos de arabia saudita no tengo
ninguna conexión con ellos
y en alguna conexión con algunos de los
familiares de jamal ha tenido algún
contacto con ellos de lo que ocurrió
no quiero responder esa pregunta lo
siento
ok en su país natal en turquía cree que
el tema sigue siendo importante pero las
autoridades de la gente que si puedo
decir que sí
y sigue siendo importante y sigue siendo
importante porque hay un juicio en curso
energía en este elemento correcto
si así es y espera que turquía pueda
llegar a una solución para que se haga
justicia
[Música]
sí eso creo porque fueron ellos quienes
le mostraron la verdad
te quiero preguntar una última cosa
cuando fue al consulado llama le estaba
buscando documentos para poder casarse
con usted sus restos nunca fueron
encontrados qué es esto para usted el
aspecto más doloroso de la historia no
poder seguir adelante porque no se sabe
dónde están sus restos
si es una parte muy grande de lo que he
pedido no tuvimos ninguna respuesta a
esta pregunta y aún no sé dónde está su
cuerpo y también fue muy doloroso para
mí no puede tocarlo por última vez darle
un último adiós eso me hacía recordarlo
todos los días en cierto modo yo no no
puede creer lo que pasó porque su cuerpo
desapareció
y como lo dije sino un último adiós es
realmente difícil de creer lo que pasa
[Música]
hay 6
esta sería mi última pregunta si confían
que las autoridades turcas pudieran
eventualmente localizar su cuerpo lo que
realmente lo están buscando activamente
sí eso creo y espero creo en eso
pichén this quiero agradecerle mucho por
ser nuestra invitada y en la revista de
france 24 desde estambul
y gracias de nada
y gracias a ustedes por ver esta
entrevista aquí en france24
[Música]